obiwi vous f1 qui on est on est on est
les frères inc pierre abandonnés par
leur propriétaire est bien décidé à
démarcher une sorte de club
sauf qu'on mort et qu'ont griffes et
j'en ai emmené nous non sans façon
mascotte vous empester la domestication
à pleigne truffe
vous avez choisi votre camp vous allez
finir en dogme nord attendait un peu
nous chaut chiens domestiques on n'a
rien de domestique vous avez tout faux
on est comme vous les gars on est les
humains ouais ouais grave c'est vrai
nous faut pas nous parler des bipèdes
j'ai par les audois on a tous les deux
brûler nos collègues est carrément web
brûlé réduit ensemble et on a tué nos m
way une minute tu as peut-être un peu
loin là non anne riff ouais on les
affuble bay zigouiller a pas tenir
chaque mètre que j'ai tué si j'avais
reçu un dollar at de ouf j'aurai un
dollar velin vu que j'ai tué que celui 1